christophe dominici donc vous mesurer à
m 73 vous peser quoi 80 kilos en plus de
83 82 83 métailié gauche au stade
français oui dirigée par max guazini oui
que je salue ici c'est bien ouais et
sympa mac très très septembre à en
parler votre look là vos cheveux un peu
mais chez blond comme ça c'est une idée
à qui c'est pas une idée c'est je trouve
que ça ça embellit un petit peu près ça
vous trouvez que ça vous embellie au
même type est vrai très festing sa
festing là c'est pour ça vous aimez les
popstars bois
ah oui vous aimer le rugby
j'adore ta et j'ai de la chance même si
j'aime ses cheveux et vous aimez son
sport
si vous avez des photos avec cher oui
comment elle et de prêts très très bien
en fait
mais est-ce que ça se voit non pas du
tout ah bon un nom elle est très très
belle course on a donc des finalistes de
la coupe du monde en 99 tournoi des six
nations ont fait partie de l'équipe de
france qui a battu le pays de galles 3 à
36 le 5 février dernier et le design on
attendait ses pas et le 19 février donc
vous tourner dans vous jouez dans le
tournoi des six nations france
angleterre mais qui sera sur france 2 je
le dis c'est sur france 2 vous vous
coucher de bonne heure là oui c'est un
peu tard déjà non non ça va ça va ouais
vous avez la permission de keller en
général me mettre au lit non sérieux non
pas du tout pas loin je m'endors
traiterait tarn
ah bon ouais non cela va leurs services
à 8 heures avec un bon p'tit déj peu
après portant donc vous jouez dans la
sélection ont été sélectionnés par la
porte et elle a donc vous jouez pas
demain avec le stade français contre
ogeu vous êtes dispensé
ici j'ai joué vous jouer quand même et
vous fatigue dit non non non non non non
ouais alors la porte a dit en parlant de
vous connaissez la porte le type du
stade français qui a entraîné l'équipe
de france doit les mener ses chers
actionnaires de l'équipe de rue voilà il
a dit en parlant de christophe affamés
les joueurs près des joueurs vous
affamer des avants et des arrières vous
les enfermer dans un endroit clos vous
mettez un steak au milieu c'est lui ces
deux ministres parce que je marche
beaucoup
pardon parce que je mange beaucoup servi
et plein de points communs facile on
fait si on fait cette compétition je
gagnerai un oui tu as un diamant 2000 et
celles qui qu'est-ce que celui ci
là
vous êtes un héros pourtant la vie a
commencé d'une façon assez dure pour
vous à 14 ans vous perdez votre soeur
pas ce cadre un accident elle avait 18
ans c'est un peu votre deuxième maman et
vous dit jean voulait à la terre entière
ensuite vous enfermer chez vous vous
vous êtes révoltés par cette disparition
et vous commencez à accumuler les
conneries vous avez fait des graves
conneries voyez graverie vous avez volé
oui bonnet quoi des mobylettes des
bagnoles et des mobiliers des voitures
et ouais vous conduisait sans permis
près ça m'est arrivé vous et des
mauvaises fréquentations
bon je sais pas si on peut appeler ça
mauvaise mais j'avais des copains qui
faisait ce genre de choses 3 106 blanche
qu'est-ce qui avec 1,7 dans halo poste
j'ai conduit sans permis vous conduisait
sans permis c'est interdit pour les
femmes à la révision de conduire alors
on peut jamais avoir de permis de
conduire je vous conduisait sans permis
d'aller partout non en arabie saoudite
ici canada
c'est pas une telle tête graves fait des
conneries mais graves ou légers est en
garde à vue vous étiez ah oui quand même
comme j'étais mineure et vous laisser
sortir mais ouais mais je crois que
c'était un moment de ma vie où je me
cherchais un petit peu j'étais passé par
une période difficile et donc j'ai pris
des coups de pied aux fesses qui vont
enfin aussi qu'ils m'ont fait évoluer
ouais vous dites sans le rugby je serais
devenu un voyou
oui parce que je trouve ça m'apporte
énormément de choses de la solidarité
l'amitié est un moment de ma vie où je
n'avais normalement besoin alors vous
avez zytek le foot à un moment c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est zytek le foot vous
aviez les qualités vous dit pour être un
bon footballeur alors je vous poser
quelques questions sur le foot vous
allez me dire si on va voir si vous
intéresser au fouet
le club champion l'année dernière on
souffle pas bordeaux qui est en tête de
la d1 aujourd'hui monaco
ah oui d'efforts le meilleur buteur
cette année là actuellement je pense que
c'est
trezeguet aussi mené la personne qui a
pris la succession de courbis à l'om non
non non casoni vous êtes fort après
rugby même dans quel club joue deschamps
parme
non non non non celles ci n'ont chelsea
chelsea restée avec lui dans france
brésil
les buteurs c'est qui zidane c'est
zidane petit bravo non seulement il m'a
servi mais quand on lui pose des
questions sur le foot il répond c'est
bien laurent 94 donc vous commencez à la
première division avec toulon 97 vous
rencontrez la porte justement et qui
vous dit si tu viens à paris je ferai de
toi à l'international et vous rentrez au
stade français est aujourd'hui selon un
sondage du midi du milieu olympique qui
est le journal du rugby
vous êtes le joueur préféré des jeunes
vous saviez ça mais les vieux démons oui
mais je pense qu'ils comme ils ont vu un
petit gabarit courir ils se sont
peut-être identifié à moi c'est possible
qu'un grand retour ce biais peur là des
laumes umaga là je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça la peur met donc à aller au
moment où les âges où il était considéré
comme la meilleure équipe du monde
ouais et ça fait forcément peur
d'affronter la meilleure équipe du monde
ouais bah vous êtes à l'origine du
premier essai vous ont marqués 1 et la
france bat la nouvelle-zélande 43-31
c'est la première fois qu'il se faisait
taillée comme ça pas moi j'ai pas un
spécialiste du rugby mais c'est quand
même des mecs qui ont la réputation
d'être les plus forts effectivement
compte mais c'est dur d'expliquer
l'inexplicable puisqu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je sais pas comment on a
fait pour les battre donc on avait
on ne va avoir énormément de choses si
on devait certainement le mériter ce
jour et permet un vrai délire on a même
vu ce jour là des anglais à twickenham
qui chantait la marseillaise donc c'est
vrai que vous dites j'avais l'impression
que ma soeur me regarder d'en haut
vous avez senti chez passion peut
appeler ça sans tiers mais c'est vrai
quand on passe aux personnes qu'on aime
elle nous aide quelquefois il ya eu la
finale contre l'australie mais là vous
étiez pourquoi vous étiez fatigué vous
étiez déjà allé trop loin et je pense
qu'ils étaient plus forts et ça faisait
2 1 qui préparaient leur titre de
champions du monde et nous l a préparé
une semaine avec le temps n'est pas du
tout le même lieu non mais je pense
qu'ils étaient plus forts on aurait
caché certaines juin
si on aurait été champion du monde donc
c'est bien qu'ils ont gagné c'est bien
qu'il soit souvent vous allez gagner le
tournoi des six nations là mais j'espère
j'espère bien on va faire une interview
première fois en baisse la lumière ne
bouge pas perdre en djing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je changeais de l'exemple de la magie
mais je comprends pas bien intérêt ouais
c'est vrai ça remarque l'image vous avez
des petits moyens
déjà je sers helmut newton premier
souvenir premier souvenir est votre
premier souvenir de votre vie c'est dur
ça n'ont cessé de leur moi j'en ai vu
des jeunes joueurs ne soutient pas donc
si ça c'est sa relation sexuelle ah bon
vous assez ça vous êtes la mouna oui
j'étais vous souvenez c'est pas très
vite dans une cage d'escalier laissant
seuls les ascenseurs quand on est quand
on ne fait pas exprès je veux dire c'est
beaucoup moins drôle
c'est vrai votre premier objet fétiche
je peux pas le dire dans l'ascenseur
aussi vraiment ouais le premier péché le
vol le vol
ouais vous souvenez ce que c'était
c'est le porte-monnaie de votre mère au
début non non il a piqué un ballon et
personne l'a rattrapé la marque et ses
petites voitures le croit ouais petites
voitures dans des boutiques web votre
premier jour à l'école vous en souvenez
très difficile ouais et le premier jour
au stade français je me suis demandé ce
que je fais là j'ai eu beaucoup de
nouvelles têtes renouvelle entraîneur
nouvelle président je me suis dit j'ai
peut-être pas fils le meilleur choix le
premier rideau hall enrico c'était qui
ma première idéale vous maintenant on à
madonna a dit dont madonna votre mari
vous en a voulu
ah oui l'histoire de madonna connaissez
pas l'histoire quand il prit madonna
justify my love c'était votre mari est
une chanson très non mais à la fin vous
savez ce qu'elle a dit non ce qu'on peut
le dire ça la telline français on peut
tout dire dans cette émission on peut
tout dire à la fin des facs oui oui mon
ex mari était en train de prier alors il
se lève il prend le cv il le jette par
la sphère en disant je ne veux plus
jamais entendre parler de cette femme
chez moi à oui les vannes rigau qui
passait en twingo et éviter l'accident
de j'ai évacué évacue premier flirt
ça vous a pas laissé un souvenir
impérissable premiers trous de mémoire
[Rires]
je voulais lui parler
oui non non je me souviens la première
fois avec une fille vous en souvenez là
oui bon d'accord et avec un garçon c'est
la grande s'est très mal passé
donc c'est mal passé m vous avez pu
recommencer donc j'ai essayé une fois
quand même c'est bien il faut essayer
devrait s'appeler s'appelait pas la
manche plaisanté j'ai jamais essayé
il va tomber ses potes qui va voir n'ont
même jamais eu envie d'essayer non non
c'est marrant ça commence à essayer way
s'est bien passé non mais j'ai essayé
d'accord et la première fois à plusieurs
reprises mais oui et alors sympathique
bon si tu sors en même temps que les
autres ça lui rappelle des trucs sympa
j'en ai mal à y aller tu as vu son
visage s'est illuminé les combien de
filles comme garçons doivent être
maintenant trois garçons deux filles
espagne ouais bah voilà canal ce tous
les jours non abonnés à canal
quand on fréquente comme gildas et 321
première cuite douloureuse douloureuse
pastis oui nivet pastis et 20 et du rose
et du pastis fait connaissez un haricot
à saint tropez l'été et non regarde le
1er juin
mardi 9h30 17 ans vous a laissé un
souvenir impérissable
oui très mauvais ah bon vous ai plus
jamais recommencer
non il a marqué contre ça vous êtes
international de rugby certainement je
me disais aussi première ecstasy jamais
jamais pour ça que vous êtes
international des six premiers millions
pas encore pas encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'astucieux
[Applaudissements]
bah oui vraiment génome vous a été très
sympathique que je voulais je vais me
faire un petit cadeau
ouais c'est le nouvel hymne du stade
français ah oui life is so strong
[Applaudissements]
avant c'était wilson chez vous qui avez
passé le stade français c'est qu'ils
avaient relancé à will survive et ça
c'est un original sa wii va très bien
merci beaucoup j'écouterai en pensant à
vous merci christophe dominici
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu